SPEAKER 1: I've worked at
Hillsdale College for a little
over 20 years now, which
is hard to believe.
But it's been a lot of fun
to watch the college grow
and extend its reach
nationwide, guided all the while
by the college's original
1844 founding mission.
As our trustee Chris
Bachelder mentioned,
on campus, the quality of
the faculty and the students
is better than ever.
And off campus, more Americans
learn from Hillsdale College
than ever before, just
think of the more than 5.6
million readers of Imprimis
or the more than 2.5
million Americans who have
signed up and taken one or more
of our online courses.
While we go about
our work every day
at Hillsdale under the
direction and leadership
of our next speaker,
he's been the pilot
of the Hillsdale College ship
for almost 21 years this year.
He's a scholar of
Winston Churchill.
He's a prolific and
best-selling author.
He's a professor of
history and politics,
including a recent course
on totalitarian novels.
You may not know that he's
also a big fan of baseball
and tennis.
And he's an avid motorcyclist.
In recent years, he's
led a two-wheeled gang
on a big summer road trip.
I don't know where
they're going this year.
But he may tell us.
Would you please
welcome to the podium,
the 12th president of Hillsdale
College, Larry P. Arnn.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY ARNN: Thank you, Tim.
This year we're
going to the Ozarks.
Because I'm from Arkansas, and
I want to see all my cousins.
If you think 2020
was bad, wait till it
turns 21 and starts drinking.
Kathy Kramer, where's Kathy?
Hold up your hand Kathy.
Yeah, she's ordered me to
give you reason for optimism.
So I'm going to say
a bunch of bad stuff.
There are things to worry about.
We're suffering from
a mental pandemic.
And that has caused
them to interfere
with the rights of
millions of Americans,
destroyed their businesses.
Our governor in Michigan, a
brilliant stateswoman she is,
too.
She spends her days,
you know, she's
got more than 1,000
pages of rules.
And they're
contradictory and stupid.
And the first thing is, if
you know how to run anything,
you know rules are
always a bad idea.
You know, when I came
to Hillsdale College,
we had 134 pages
of student rules.
Now we have 17 rules, not
pages of rules, rules, right.
And that means we
can kind of know
what they are, although 17 is
too many to carry in your mind.
The one great rule
is behave yourself.
Be good.
They swear an oath and an
honor code to do that, right.
And that's really the
only rule you need.
But she's like that, right.
And she has messed
with our college.
Right now, the score is
Hillsdale, 3, governor, 0.
[APPLAUSE]
But it's irksome.
Because, you know, somebody--
some supposed right-wingers
that disappeared
when they found out
they were Antifa people
had a plot to kidnap her.
And so I was asked
by a journalist,
would you know anybody
who'd want to do that?
And I said, I don't know anybody
who'd even like to meet her.
[LAUGHTER]
See, that's optimism, Kathy.
That's a tragic thing I'm
describing, but it's funny,
you know.
The election was a mass of
corruption and disorder.
[APPLAUSE]
Tomorrow, I'm going to tell you
about some state legislators
in an unnamed state that might
be one that I would know a lot
about, whatever state that was.
And it will make you sad.
Also, it will show
us what to do.
And now, the government
is in the hands
of radical liberalism.
Oh, I got to have my prop.
Grace, bring me that
book over there.
This is the great Grace Balkan.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh yeah, also that--
the prayer girl, Taryn Murphy,
outstanding senior woman,
and she is dating
the useless Grant
Wood who's about to go
into the Marine Corps.
And I think now that
she's reached her glory,
she'll see better than that.
[LAUGHTER]
Actually, Grant is a very
fine young man just unworthy
of Taryn.
So on the first day of
the Biden administration,
we were up first.
He canceled the 1776 Commission
and erased the report
from the White House.
They were mad at it
because we had five weeks
to form a commission, have
meetings, write a report,
agree to it unanimously,
and then design, publish it,
and get it out.
And we were destroyed because
the government doesn't
like things to move like that.
But now it's been completely
obliterated, except wait--
[APPLAUSE]
It's just been published
by Encounter Books.
And we've added footnotes.
And the footnotes
are to two things.
They're to original
source documents,
and they are to leading
historians, some of whom
have attacked us, who say
exactly the same thing
in their own books.
So that'll be fun.
It's a little book.
You should get it.
Write me, and I'll
send it to you.
Also Joe Biden is
the honorary chair
of our marketing campaign.
[LAUGHTER]
At last, somewhere
where he's effective.
The worst thing of
all is they're messing
with the electoral system.
And I'll talk about
that some tomorrow.
But the truth is, in
a representative form
of government, the linchpin
of it, the crucial point,
is the voting system.
And so I believe that
in the Obama years
they figured out
that, unexpectedly,
people don't actually
like what they do.
And so they might have reformed
and moderated themselves.
But instead what
they did was they
decided we're
going to make them.
And I think we're living
under that effort right now.
So that's the bad stuff.
How am I doing, Kathy?
But I know three pieces of
delightful news, powerful news.
Two, I'm going to tell you right
now and the other one tomorrow.
The first one is Hillsdale
College is just thriving.
It's just marvelous to us.
[APPLAUSE]
And we're stubborn cusses.
And we're not given to
counting our successes.
Because when we're
dead, we can do that.
But, you know, it's been
successful for a long time.
Now it's more.
It's just amazing.
Like our entering
class next year
is going to have an entering
standardized test score
one point below the Ivy League.
So it's about 25th
in the country.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
And we could fill up another
college at those standards now.
And everything is like that.
You've been very
generous with us.
Thank you very much.
Our students are
now paying about 7%
of the budget of
Hillsdale College.
And that means we don't need
them, and we can tell them so.
[LAUGHTER] And that's
really good for them.
Because, you know,
they'll be spoiled babies
if we don't torture them.
Do you know how many
people get Imprimis?
Almost six million,
isn't that crazy?
And do you know many people have
registered for online courses
at Hillsdale College in the
last, what is it, 8 or 9 years?
Almost three million, growing
faster now than previously.
And what are those
courses, right?
The latest one is Euclid.
It's already got 10,000
people taking it.
Aristotle, Dante is
coming soon, right.
What-- isn't that an
amazing phenomenon?
I get recognized
in airports now.
And-- and people walk up
to me, and they talk to me
like they're students,
just like on the campus.
Oh, you're Dr. Arnn.
And I say, yes, indeed.
And he says, well, we
just love your course.
And I say, are you
taking the exams?
And they do exactly
what students do.
They look at their feet
and kind of shuffle around.
[LAUGHING] They're afraid I'm
going to look up their score.
That's all good news.
And I submit to you, Kathy
Kramer, world-changing news.
Just remember, all the best
things, every great thing
ever done in human
history is done
by a volunteer and somebody
who does it for love.
[APPLAUSE]
Second great news tonight
is our speaker tonight.
Somewhere near the
center of our problems,
I'll talking about
this a little tomorrow
because I learned it
from Winston Churchill,
is the corruption of the ancient
and natural way of knowing
called natural science.
It's a beautiful thing.
We know more about the
material and the natural world
than we ever have.
But the weight of
those disciplines
has turned not from science--
from science, it just means
knowing in Latin to technology,
which means making.
And making is not the
same thing as knowing.
Making is an exercise in power.
So it's no accident
that we are governed
by supposedly scientists.
I mean, I can talk all day
about the governor of Michigan.
I've still managed-- if she
was beating me, I would--
it'd be heart rending to me.
But so far, we're doing pretty
good, so I can talk about her.
She was asked, there are, what,
40,000 or 50,000, Scott Atlas
will know, medical
researchers and some
of the many of the leading
epidemiologists in the world
who've signed the Great
Barrington Declaration, which
says, this is all crazy.
You know, Facebook took
it down the other day.
I had an argument with a medical
doctor, a friend, a good guy,
at the Mayo Clinic.
And he said, well, you're
using the epidemiologists that
are for opening up.
And I said, correct.
And he said, you
knew that already.
And I said, yeah, what
do you think I'm running,
a scientific experiment here?
I'm running a college.
It's my duty to have college.
It's my duty to find
a way that's safe.
Because, as I tell the
students all the time,
if you get sick
and die from this,
it's going to be very
inconvenient to me.
[LAUGHTER]
Which, you know, it's true.
And I have a stake in
protecting them, right.
But on the other hand, my
job is to have college.
So this doctor, who's got
kids at Hillsdale College
and came to our commencement.
I said, you've just
proved my point.
And he said, how?
And I said, you guys are the
best in the world at Mayo
Clinic, aren't you?
He said, we're pretty good.
And I said, how about
these guys at Stanford?
Are they pretty good?
And he says, yeah.
And I said, see,
you don't agree.
Experts never do about
a practical judgment.
They will, by the way,
eventually reach an agreement
about the facts
that can be measured
if they're any use at all.
But this thing about what
to do about this pandemic
when you have the
power to shut down
the largest economy in
the history of the world.
That's a thing of massive and
incalculable consequences.
And nobody can be
an expert in that.
And he said, well,
you got a good point.
And I said, thank you very much.
And on the other
hand, I did need
to know if I was going
to kill these kids.
Because I say, it'd just cause
me a world of trouble if I did.
Where'd I learn that?
Three people, one of
them our speaker tonight.
Three top people, and three
people, who it turns out,
are brave.
Because they stood
up against this.
Their names, or the
ones who helped us,
are Jay Bhattacharya
from Stanford
and Daniel Halperin from
North Carolina and then,
the toughest of them all, Scott
Atlas, our speaker tonight.
[CHEERING]
And, you know, a great,
intellectual argument
is always some wisdom of
intellectual and moral power.
Because you have to be
brave to speak the truth
in the face of consequences.
Scott Atlas is one of
the leading physicians
in the world.
He wrote the book on
magnetic resonance imaging
of the brain and the spine.
And somehow, in the
course of writing on that,
he delivered-- he developed
both and he's just strong.
He did work for the
president, for President Trump
for a while.
And the point is, it's
such a violent culture
today that for a
leading scientist
to offer his counsel to the
President of the United States,
when there are people
dying as there are,
and that is a disgrace.
That tells you where
the country is.
I say, he's a
cause for optimism.
Because I didn't know him
before any of this came up.
And so that means that I, and
all of us, every one of us,
has discovered a brave
and brilliant man.
And the only correct
conclusion to draw from that
is there must be more.
And we are stronger
by knowing him.
Please come up here Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
As you know, Hillsdale
College is very old, not long
in the tooth.
And there's an award
that I'm about to give
Scott we've been giving
here for more than 40 years.
And we've given it
to Ronald Reagan.
to Margaret Thatcher.
And we've given it
to Clarence Thomas
and some other small names.
And it's called the
Freedom Leadership Award.
And that means leadership
which takes courage
toward freedom, which
has a generosity
to everyone it touches.
I'm proud to present this
award to Scott Atlas.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT ATLAS: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you President Arnn,
supporters of Hillsdale,
and Hillsdale National
Leadership Seminar Program,
and members of this
distinguished audience.
It's a great honor to be here.
It's my first
exposure to Hillsdale.
And it's awesome.
I am really thrilled to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm very, very grateful
to receive the award.
I'm, of course, highly honored
to be on the list of winners.
And I sincerely
thank everyone who
had anything to do with this.
It's also great to be in a crowd
that is friendly for a change.
[LAUGHTER]
Hillsdale's National
Leadership Seminar Program,
as everyone here
knows, was founded
with a specific mission,
quote, to foster
enlightened leadership and
informed decision-making
for America's third
century, by communicating
the fundamental principles
of freedom and order
on which Western civilization
is based, unquote.
The pandemic has been
a tragedy, no doubt.
But it has exposed
profound issues in America
that now threaten those very
principles of freedom and order
that we Americans too
often take for granted.
First, I must say I was
shocked at the enormous power
of the government to
unilaterally decree
to simply close
businesses and schools,
restrict personal movement,
mandate behavior, eliminate
our most basic freedoms
without any end.
And second, I was,
and I remain, stunned
and a little bit frightened
at the acquiescence
of the American people to these
destructive, arbitrary, and
wholly unscientific rules,
restrictions, and mandates.
[APPLAUSE]
This crisis also exposed
what we have all known
existed, but we tolerated.
Although I think Hillsdale
didn't tolerate it
as much as everyone else.
But the rest of the
country tolerated for years
the bias of the media, the
suppression of academic freedom
on campuses, the lack of
neutrality in big tech,
and now, more
obviously than ever,
the politicization of science.
Ultimately, the freedom to
seek and state the truth
is at risk here in
the United States.
First, we all acknowledge
the consequences of the SARS2
coronavirus pandemic and its
management have been enormous.
Over 500,000
American deaths have
been attributed to the virus.
More will certainly follow.
Even after a year, the pandemic
still paralyzes our country.
And despite all efforts, there
has been an undeniable failure
to stop the cases from rapidly
escalating and preventing
hospitalizations and death.
But here's the
unacknowledged reality.
Almost every state
and major city
has implemented severe
restrictions for many months,
including closures of businesses
and in-person schools,
mobility restrictions, curfews,
quarantines, limits on groups
and families, and mask
mandates dating back to
at least the summer.
And let's clear up the
myths about the behavior
of Americans.
Social mobility tracking and
data from Gallup, YouGov,
the COVID-19
Consortium, and the CDC
have shown significant
reductions of movement,
as well as consistently
high percentage
of mask wearing since
late last summer,
similar to Western Europe
and approaching that in Asia.
There is no truth to the fact
that these mandates were not
obeyed.
All legitimate
policy scholars today
should be re-examining
policies that severely
harmed Americans
families and children
and failed to save the elderly.
Numerous studies, including
one from my current institution
Stanford University's
infectious disease scientists
and epidemiologists Bendavid,
Oh, Bhattacharya, and Ioannidis
have shown the mitigating impact
of these extraordinary measures
used in almost every
state was small at best.
President Biden openly
admitted this lack of efficacy
in his speech on January
22 when he said, quote,
there is nothing
we can do to change
the trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months,
unquote.
Bizarrely though,
many want to blame
those who oppose the lockdowns
an the mandates for the failure
of the lockdowns and
the mandates that
were widely implemented.
Separate from their
limited value efficacy that
has been grossly exaggerated
in scientific journals,
lockdown policies have been
extraordinarily harmful.
The harms to children of
closing in-person schools
are dramatic, poor
learning, school dropouts,
social isolation, suicidal
ideation, most of which
are far worse for
lower income families.
A recent study confirms
up to 78% of cancers
were never detected due to
missed screen over three
months.
And extrapolating to
the entire country,
over a million new cases
over 9 months of cancer
will have gone undetected.
That disaster adds
to missed surgeries,
delayed presentations of
pediatric illnesses, heart
attack, and stroke patients
too afraid to call emergency
services, and others,
all well documented.
Beyond hospital care, the CDC
reported fourfold increases
in depression, tripling of
anxiety symptoms, doubling
of suicidal ideation,
particularly
among young adults.
After the first few
months of lockdowns,
domestic abuse, child
abuse skyrocketing
due to the isolation
and, specifically,
to the loss of jobs,
particularly in strict lockdown
states.
Given that many in-person
schools have closed,
hundreds of thousands of child
abuse cases are not reported.
Because schools are where child
abuse is most frequently noted.
Finally, the unemployment
shock from the lockdowns,
according to a
recent NBER study,
will generate almost 890,000
additional US deaths,
mainly in minority
and poor families,
over the next 15 years.
That's the lockdown alone.
We know we have not seen the
full extent of the damage.
Because it will
last for decades.
Perhaps that is why
lockdowns were never
recommended in previous
pandemic analysis,
even for infections with
far higher death rates.
To determine the
best path forward,
shouldn't policymakers
now objectively
consider both the virus harms
and the totality of impact
of the policies to date?
That's the importance of health
policy experts, my field.
We have a broader
scope of expertise
than that of epidemiologists
and basic scientists,
who you see on TV every day.
And that necessarily
means admitting
that social lockdowns and
significant restrictions
on individuals are
deadly, extraordinarily
harmful, especially
on the working class
minorities and the poor.
Optimistically, we
should be seeing
the light at the end
of the long tunnel
now with the vaccine rollout.
On the other hand,
using logic that
would put Alice in Wonderland's
Mat Hatter to shame,
the new vaccines were first
more frequently administered
to healthier, younger
people, instead of those
at risk to die in most states.
And now we hear children must be
vaccinated before schools open
when they have extremely
low risk from this infection
and are proven to not
be significant spreaders
to adults.
Or the Kafkaesque
nonsense that teachers
must be vaccinated before
they teach in person, when
schools are one of the
lowest risk environments.
And the vast majority of
teachers are not high risk.
Even worse, we hear the same
old so-called experts on TV
now warning that social
distancing, masks,
and other restrictions
will still
be necessary after vaccines.
There is no intention
of those in power
to allow Americans to live
normally, to live freely again,
and don't ever think otherwise.
[APPLAUSE]
Just as in Galileo's time, the
real problem is what he called,
quote, vested academic
interests, unquote.
Many universities, which
should be America's centers
for critical thinking, have
overtly intimidated views
contrary to their own,
undoubtedly, undeniably out
of political reasons, leaving
many afraid to speak up.
I know, I get their emails for
months, people encouraging me
but are afraid to step forward.
But it is not only the
matter of academic freedom
that needs comment.
Instead of rethinking
the failed policies,
some Stanford
professors have chosen
to employ toxic smears
and opinion pieces
and organized rebukes
against those of us
who disagreed with what was
implemented but worse who dared
to help the country under
a president they despised,
apparently the
ultimate transgression.
Defamatory attacks
with malicious intent
based on straw man arguments
and out of context distortions
are not acceptable
in civilized society,
let alone in our universities.
In their attempt to
intimidate and discredit me
using falsifications
and misrepresentations,
a group of untruthful professors
violated, with impunity,
Stanford's code of conduct,
damaged the Stanford name,
and, most importantly, abused
the trust parents in society
place in them to influence
America's children,
our next generation of leaders.
This is unacceptable.
It is understandable that most
Stanford professors are not
experts in my field,
health policy,
and even that most are ignorant
of the data about the pandemic.
But it is not
acceptable to claim
I made recommendations that
were, quote, falsehoods
and misrepresentations
of science.
That is a lie.
And no matter how often a lie
is repeated and regardless
of how often those lies
are echoed in the media,
lies do not transform
into truths.
We all must pray to God
that the phrase attributed
to Nazi propagandist
Joseph Goebbels, quote,
a lie told once remains
a lie, but a lie
told 1,000 times becomes
the truth, unquote, never
becomes true in these
United States of America.
[APPLAUSE]
All policy considerations I
recommended to the president
were designed to reduce
both the spread of the virus
to the most vulnerable
and the harms to those
impacted by the
policies the most,
the poor and working
class of America.
I was one of the first to push
for increasing protections
to those most at risk,
particularly the elderly.
Almost a year ago,
I recognized we
must consider the enormous
harms to physical health,
mental health, and lives
lost coming directly
from the draconian
policies that attempted
to contain the infection.
That is the most
appropriate goal
of people in public health
policy, to minimize all harms,
not simply to stop
COVID-19 at all costs.
[APPLAUSE]
The claim in a recent Journal
of the AMA opinion piece,
a vicious piece written by three
Stanford professors, that said,
quote, nearly all public
health experts were concerned
that Atlas' recommendations
could lead to tens of thousands
of unnecessary deaths in
the United States alone,
unquote, is patently
false, absurd on its face.
As Professor Arnn
mentioned, the proposal
called the Great Barrington
Declaration, co-authored
by some of the world's
best medical scientists
and epidemiologists from
Stanford, Harvard, and Oxford,
is, quote, far closer to the one
condemned in the JAMA article
than anything Atlas
said, unquote,
as pointed out by Zinberg.
Yet that policy
document has already
been signed by over 50,000
medical and public health
practitioners.
When critics display
such ignorance
about the scope of
views held by experts,
it exposes their overt bias
and wholly disqualifies
their authority on these issues.
Indeed, it is
almost beyond parody
that these same
Stanford critics wrote,
quote, professionalism demands
honesty about what they
know and do not know, unquote.
It is true that I have
explained the fact
that younger people have little
risk from this infection,
as well as the biological
concept of herd
immunity, the most
radioactive term
in the pandemic discussion.
That explanation is very
different from proposing
that people be deliberately
exposed and infected.
I have never done that.
To the contrary,
I have repeatedly
called for mitigation
measures, including
extra sanitization,
social distancing, masks
when appropriate,
group limits, testing,
and other increased
protections to limit the spread
and the damage from the virus.
I explicitly call for augmenting
protection of those at risk
in dozens of on the
record presentations,
interviews, and written pieces.
Yet one must question
why these accusers ignore
these explicit
emphatic denials of me,
beyond those
presentations, that I ever
supported spreading the
infection unchecked to achieve
herd immunity.
These denials were quoted
widely in the media.
Are not my own
statements the object
of their criticism
in the first place?
Or might it be something else?
Might it be due to these
Stanford professor's
own political rage,
their own desire
to delegitimize anyone
who had the audacity
to help the country
under President Trump.
[APPLAUSE]
For many months, I was
vilified after calling
for opening in-person
schools, the same exact policy
that Harvard professors
Martin Kulldorf and Katherine
Yee and Stanford professor,
and my good friend, Jay
Bhattacharya called for.
But this policy has
been corroborated,
upheld with all the evidence
repeatedly for months.
The compelling case
to open schools
is admitted to be long
standing truth now,
even in lay publications
like The Atlantic.
They said, quote, research
from around the world
has, since the beginning
of the pandemic,
indicated that people under
18 and especially younger kids
are less susceptible
to infection,
less likely to experience
severe symptoms,
and far less likely to be
hospitalized or die, unquote.
And quote, we've
known for months
that young children
are less susceptible
to serious infection and less
likely to transmit the virus.
Let's act like it, unquote.
The JAMA accusers further
stated, Atlas disputed the need
for masks, unquote.
Talk about radioactive issues.
Let's talk about masks.
To the contrary, my advice
on mask usage was consistent.
And I said it more
than 100 times.
Wear a mask when you cannot
socially distance, quote,
unquote.
What's funny is that that
matches almost verbatim
the published recommendations of
the World Health Organization.
Quote, when outside, wear a mask
if you cannot maintain physical
distance from others, unquote.
And in December, they changed
it to, quote, in areas where
the virus is circulating, masks
should be worn when you're
in crowded settings,
when you can't
be one meter from
others, and in rooms
with poor or unknown
ventilation, unquote, i.e.
not at all times by everyone.
That also matches the NIH.
Quote, when consistent
distancing is not possible,
face coverings may
further reduce the spread
of infectious droplets from
individuals with SARS2 COVID
infection to others, unquote.
You'll never hear that on CNN.
You may not watch CNN.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Let's talk about
universal mask usage
in the general population.
38 states have implemented
mask mandates, most
since at least the summer with
almost all the rest having
major city mask mandates.
Widespread general
population mask usage
has shown little
empirical utility
for stopping cases all
over the world, every state
in the country, even though
describing that evidence
has been censored.
Widespread mass usage
shows only minimal impact
in the one large randomized
controlled study from Denmark.
Here's the reality.
Those who insist that universal
mask usage is absolutely
proven effective at controlling
the spread of this virus
and somehow is universally
recommended by the science
are deliberately ignoring
the evidence to the contrary.
And they are propagating false
and misleading information.
[APPLAUSE]
Those who charge that it
is unethical or dangerous
to question broad
population mask mandates
must explain why several of the
world's top infectious disease
scientists and public
health organizations overtly
questioned the efficacy of
general population mask.
Jefferson and Heneghan
of Oxford Center
for Evidence-Based
Medicine wrote,
quote, it would appear
that, despite two
decades of pandemic
preparedness,
there is considerable
uncertainty as to value
of wearing masks, unquote.
Oxford's Sunetra Gupta said,
there is no need for masks
unless one is
elderly or high risk.
Stanford's Jay Bhattacharya
stated, quote, mask mandates
are not supported by
the scientific data.
There is no scientific
evidence that mask mandates
work to slow the spread
of the disease, unquote.
Throughout the
pandemic, the WHO said,
at present, there is
no direct evidence
on the effectiveness
of universal masking
of healthy people in the
community to prevent infection
with respiratory viruses,
including COVID-19, unquote.
The CDC reviewed influenza
pandemics and published in May.
Quote, they did
not find evidence
that surgical type
face masks are
effective in reducing
laboratory confirmed influenza
transmission, either when
worn by infected persons
source control or by persons in
the general community to reduce
their susceptibility, unquote.
And until the WHO
removed the quote
that I used of theirs in my
tweet, that was withdrawn
and censored by
Twitter, they had
posted, until the very next
day, quote, at the present time,
the widespread use of masks by
healthy people in the community
setting is not yet
supported by high quality
or direct scientific evidence.
And there are potential benefits
and harms to consider, period.
At this point, one
could make a strong case
that those who continue to
push societal restrictions
without acknowledging their
failures and serious harms
are themselves putting forth
dangerous misinformation.
But I will not call for their
official rebuke or punishment.
I will not try to cancel them.
I will not try to
extinguish their opinions.
And I will not lie to distort
their words and defame them.
To do so would repeat
their shameful behavior
of intimidating
discourse that is
critical to educating
the public and arriving
at the scientific truth
we desperately need.
It's time to consider
that university models,
like Harvard's truth, Stanford's
the winds of freedom blow,
and Yale's light and
truth need major revision.
Social media has piled
on with a heavy hand
now to eliminate discussion
of conflicting evidence.
Without permitting,
without indeed encouraging,
open debate and
admission of errors,
we might never solve
any future crisis.
As a health policy
scholar for over 15 years
and as a professor at top
universities for 30 years,
I am shocked at what I see.
Some faculty members of
our acclaimed universities
are now dangerously
intolerant, dangerously
intolerant of opinions
that they don't agree with.
[APPLAUSE]
Some go even further,
distorting and misrepresenting
words to delegitimize and
even calling for punishment
of those of us willing
to serve the country
alongside a polarizing president
that they happen to loathe.
It is their behavior to quote
those same professors rebuking
me that, quote, violates the
core values of Stanford faculty
and the expectations under
the Stanford code of conduct,
which states, quote, we are
all responsible for sustaining
the high ethical standards
of this institution, unquote.
But worse than that
violation of ethical behavior
among colleagues,
their behavior does not
meet the standard of
simple human decency.
If academic leaders, if the
entire academic community
fails to stand up and renounce
that unethical conduct,
many more experts with
a reputation to lose
will be unwilling to serve their
country in contentious times.
As educators, as parents,
as fellow citizens,
that would be the
worst possible legacy
to leave to our children.
I also fear that the
concept the science
has been seriously damaged.
[APPLAUSE]
Even the best journals in the
world, New England Journal
of Medicine, Lancet, Science,
Nature, and Journal of the AMA
have become overtly
contaminated by politics.
Many, unfortunately,
have now become
fatigued by these arguments.
That is even worse.
Because if the public
becomes fatigued,
that will allow a fallacy
to triumph over truth.
If the social media
continues to be
the arbiter of
allowable discussion,
the United States
is on the precipice
of losing its
cherished freedoms,
with censorship and
cancellation of all those
who bring views forward that
differ from the accepted
mainstream.
I stand here
honestly more renewed
than I was when I
walked in this building,
because I have never seen
Hillsdale College before.
[APPLAUSE]
I will say this in conclusion.
While it is not clear if
our democracy will survive,
it is obvious that people must
step up, and I may say rise up,
or it has no chance.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[CHEERING]
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you, Dr. Atlas.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please raise your hand
and wait for a microphone
to be brought to you.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: I am 75
years old and sort
of on the horns of a dilemma.
And that dilemma is whether
or not to get the vaccination.
So what's your opinion
of what we should
do under these circumstances.
SCOTT ATLAS: OK.
This is a common
question actually
tonight before the dinner.
So I mean, I'll first say,
I'm not anybody's doctor here.
And you should consult
with your doctor.
I can say this, and this
is what I tell people.
I think, and I've said it on
the podium in the press briefing
room, so I feel that
people who are at risk
should get the vaccine.
And what I mean by that
is, besides the people
who have high risk conditions,
people who are generally
over roughly 65, it's
advisable to get the vaccine.
And I say that for two reasons.
One is that the
risk of the vaccine
is smaller than the
risk from COVID-19
for people who are old.
I consider myself--
I don't consider myself old,
but I did get the vaccine
two days ago.
And the second reason is
sort of a secondary reason,
but it's the reality of
the country we're living
and the world we're living in.
I believe, I don't
want it to be true.
But I believe that
we're probably
going to be required
to show that we
had the vaccine before we're
allowed to do certain things.
I actually believe that.
It's sad.
But this is the world
we're looking at.
And what I'm talking
about specifically
is things like
international travel.
I believe-- I have no
inside knowledge on this.
I'm not in the
discussion at all--
that countries could easily
start requiring that.
And I do travel quite a bit.
So those two things in
the right age group,
I think it's advisable
to get the vaccine.
And I think it probably will
be required, although I have
no inside knowledge on that.
If you're asking me, should
everyone get the vaccine?
Again, I'm going to say it's
a personal decision with you
and your doctor.
I do not believe,
for one second,
that people should be
required to get a vaccine.
No, I am completely
opposed to that.
[APPLAUSE]
If you're low risk and young,
I think there's a strong case
to not take the vaccine.
I have two children of
my own in that age group.
And I've advised
them accordingly.
But again, like it's
a personal decision.
There are certain risks.
I would say this, if I
can go on a little bit.
I was there, from what
I saw and what I know,
there were no corners cut
on the vaccine development.
In fact, there were
extra delays put
in against standards to
delay the emergency use
authorization.
So I do not believe at all that
the vaccines were somehow short
circuiting safety measures.
I disagree with that.
There is a certain
percentage of complications
from any time you're going
to inject into your body
something.
That's clear.
And vaccines are
in that category.
But it's a cost
benefit or a risk
ben-- a risk sort of benefit
assessment for an individual.
SPEAKER 2: We have a--
We have a question on
the speaker's left.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Atlas,
I just recently read,
and I can't say who quoted it.
But it was a quote
that saying that those
who had the coronavirus
and then who recovered
should only get the first
shot of the inoculation.
And I thought, presumably,
if you've had the disease,
you have the antibodies.
You have the memory
cells in your blood.
What the heck is that about that
they should get the first shot?
Do you have an opinion on that?
Have you heard that?
I can't remember who said it.
SCOTT ATLAS: Yes.
So I mean, there's two parts to
that really that are important.
One is, when you're talking
about prioritizing vaccines,
this is one of the things
that is, again, like this is--
I've said on TV I feel like I'm
living in a Kafka novel here.
I mean, there's
never been anyone
that says, in the administration
or in the people that
are in charge
nowadays, that says
that you should not
be a priority if you
had the infection.
And of course, you
should not be a priority.
I'm not saying you should
never take the vaccine.
But you don't need
it right away.
You should immunize the people
who have a high risk to die.
And if you've had the infection,
you have biological protection.
That's just-- that's fact.
That's high school AP biology.
That's not even medical school.
And that's what
the research shows.
But somehow, that's
just not discussed.
The second part of
your question is,
there is some evidence
that people that
have had the infection, when
they get the first dose,
they have the same immune
response to the first dose,
quantitatively, as a regular
person without the infection
who had both doses.
That's where that's coming from.
So if you have the X immune
response after two doses
and you've never
had the infection,
if you take somebody
who's had the infection,
gets the first dose, they
also have X immune response.
So they are sort
of fully protected
or equivalently protected.
That's where that comes from.
I don't have an opinion
on how that will be.
But I do have an
opinion that people
who have had the
infection should not
be the first priority
to get vaccinated.
We should vaccinate the people
who are at high risk to die.
That's the only
reason to do vaccines
is to stop people from dying.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SCOTT ATLAS: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I want to
first congratulate you.
It was a wonderful speech,
and it had a lot to say.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT ATLAS: Thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: Secondly,
is this going
to be available to
us in a written form
that we're allowed to ask for?
SCOTT ATLAS: I think
it's going to be--
it's on the internet if I'm
not mistaken, number one.
Number two, much
of this I'm going
to submit as a written
piece to one of the--
one of the Stanford newspapers.
Because I'm really tired
of what's going on.
And I'm not going to take it.
I'm not going to take it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Dr. Atlas,
I'll be 85 in May.
And I've been inoculated,
so I'm ready to go.
But all summer long,
I've turned on the TV.
And I saw Dr. Fauci and
Dr. Scarf telling us what
the science was in the moment.
And I was wondering if you
could elaborate a little bit as
to how much of that was science,
how much of that was politics.
SCOTT ATLAS: Well, no, I have no
hesitancy in telling the truth.
I'll tell you it this way first.
I wasn't there.
You have to remember, I didn't
come in until mid-August.
So a lot of stuff was said.
And then nothing was said.
Because then the president
discontinued these press
conferences.
What I saw inside
the White House,
inside the what's called the
situation room where the task
force meets, is incredible.
It's shocking.
It's outrageous what was said.
And I'm going to have
to write about that one,
because it's amazing.
But it's sort of
frightening the level
of knowledge, the lack of
knowledge of the current data.
And I think the answer really,
it can be summed up as this.
These are people who are
government bureaucrats.
These are people who have worked
in government jobs for 30,
40 years.
These are not people who are
challenged intellectually
by other people who come in
and say, well, what about this?
People like me, and they bring
in a dozen scientific papers
and go through the data.
That didn't happen
before I got there.
And when you have
people who are talking,
like they're talking now
on TV, about, well, we
should pass this
bill or something
like this, that's not science.
That's politics.
So I think, it's tough
to say the truth.
It's actually easy
It's tough to watch people
lie about what you said.
But a lot of things
that were said
were sort of difficult to--
difficult to
believe, I will say.
I'll leave it at that.
LARRY ARNN: To the man
who asked if you're
going to get to read
this, the answer is yes.
SCOTT ATLAS: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We have a question
on the speaker's left-- oh,
I apologize.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for your remarks tonight.
They were tremendous.
And more so, thank you for your
action in serving our country.
SCOTT ATLAS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My
question, you referred
to the incredible power
asserted by our government
to shut down the largest economy
known in the history of mankind
without having set
a goal or a purpose.
I recall early on that there was
a goal of flattening the curve,
and not necessarily
completely destroying
the virus for all
time but trying
to get the infection rate
to be below the capacities
for emergency rooms, et cetera.
Whatever happened to that,
and what is the goal?
SCOTT ATLAS: I find myself
asking that frequently.
[LAUGHTER]
You're right.
And I remember, back in the
spring or whenever that was,
the press conference that was a
very good press conference when
Dr. Birx explained
that we're going
to flatten the curve,
which only meant one thing.
The hospitalizations they didn't
want to have exceed capacity.
It had nothing to do with
stopping people from dying.
If people want to
talk mathematically,
the area under the curve
was never changing.
It was simply that they were
going to delay it so that, A,
hospitals could treat people,
including, by the way,
people without COVID,
which they failed to do.
But that was voluntary
and fear induced.
But the second
reason for the delay
was at least there was some
time for mobilizing resources,
ramping up production of
personal protective equipment,
getting a head start
on drug development.
These are all rational
reasons to temporarily,
you know, close things.
And you may or may not remember,
but President Trump very early
on, and repeatedly, said we
cannot have the cure be worse
than the disease.
And there is something
so obvious and yet so
wise about that.
It's obvious.
But nobody else was saying it.
And that is what happened.
So you're right
There has now been
a complete transformation
of the goal to stopping
all cases of COVID-19.
And it's completely irrational.
It has proven to be impossible.
And it is so destructive
and harmful that it
is one of the most egregious
failures of health care
policy, really, in the
history of the modern world.
I don't know how to
say it otherwise.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We have a question
on the speaker's left.
AUDIENCE: Hello, can
I ask you a question?
Did you know that the
Arizona state legislature
is in the process of
deciding whether people have
to wear a mask totally,
or they can get away
with not wearing a mask?
And all they have to
do is get in touch
with our state
representative and senators.
And you can contact West
Valley Republican Office.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT ATLAS: No, I didn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Good evening, thank
you for being here.
Two part question, the first
is expressing a conundrum
that I myself and
I think probably
most of the people
in this room feel
is a strong desire to rise up.
We feel powerless to make a
difference in a world that
is forcing compliance.
If you want to shop
at HomeGoods, if you
want to go to Home Depot, if
you want to go to the grocery
store, if you want to live
your life, you must mask up.
If you want to fly, if you want
to eat while you're flying,
it's up and down with the mask.
What is your advice
for those of us
who choose to believe the
science, as you have described
it, to rise up in a
way that is impactful
and can change the way and
the course that we are facing?
The second part, unrelated,
is around the power
of local public health officials
to determine local public
policy and health policy that
drive the local policies that
are really impacting how
we're living our lives.
Thank you.
SCOTT ATLAS: OK.
So the rise up
quote, by the way,
means make your voices heard.
I know that a lot of
people went insane
when I said that on Twitter.
Rise up means stand up,
make your voices heard.
That's what a
democracy is all about.
And so what I mean by how
you would do that is exactly
that you must be aggressively
contacting, meaning be vocal,
contact your representatives,
your local representatives.
You have to basically--
we have to make sure
that the people in charge
are accountable to the people
who are in the population.
And they're not accountable
if we just sit there.
And so I speak to--
I have spoken many times with
San Diego business community,
as one example.
And these guys,
these people, they
want to open their businesses.
And so they have their
city council members
sit in on these meetings.
They have their--
it's all about,
we are the people in
charge, in theory.
And so we have to really--
we have to show it.
It doesn't mean do something
destructive or violent
or anything like that.
That should be obvious to
any fair-minded person what
we're saying here.
But that means be on the
record, say what you want.
I mean, the people of
California are rising up.
There's a recall vote
going on with the governor.
[APPLAUSE]
Now the second part
of your question--
there's no simple
answer to the question.
There's no magic wand here.
But it means actually
try to be impactful
in your local communities
and get together as groups.
Because I was saying earlier
that the individual person who
owns the gym, who wants
to stand up and just open,
OK, that person is squashed.
And that just, it doesn't work.
But it works if everybody opens.
It works if all the
restaurants say, you know what?
We're open.
It works if the businesses say,
listen, we think we can open.
If you don't want to
go to a restaurant,
don't go as a customer.
That's what I say.
If you don't want to
go to a gym, don't go.
[APPLAUSE]
Now the second part is these
local public health officials,
which is really incredible.
This is, again, something
that we never knew.
We never understood who had
this kind of power before.
I live in Santa
Clara County, which
is probably the most
restricted county
in the state of California.
And this is a--
it's out of control.
It's insane.
Their numbers they're
putting up make no sense.
It's beyond arbitrary
what they're
saying are these guidelines
and measures to open.
And so the answer is--
and this is beginning.
There is now scrutiny as
to who these people are
and who are in these
positions, because they never
had any impact before.
They were really
nonentities in a sense,
at least not impactful
in our daily lives.
They have created,
by their actions,
a spotlight on themselves.
And that is the
answer is that we
need to make sure that we
are on top of these people.
These people are officials.
They're not in charge unless
we let them be in charge.
So this is sort of
a gradual process.
It's an education for all of us.
No one knew about these people.
I don't think any
of us had ever,
you know, interacted
with these people before.
So we need to make sure
that we are holding
these officials accountable,
even at the local level
not just the state
level, the local level.
They have tremendous
control of your lives.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, Dr. Atlas,
thank you for being here.
It's a pleasure to hear
your expertise this evening.
I'm just wondering,
as one who is choosing
not to get the vaccine, could
you possibly give your opinion
or speak to the effectiveness
of hydroxychloroquine
or ivermectin as treatment?
SCOTT ATLAS: OK.
We're going to hit
all these hot topics.
Yeah, I mean, OK, so
there's a lot of controversy
about all these drugs.
I'll give you a little bit
of my view of what happened
with hydroxychloroquine.
What happened with
hydroxychloroquine was,
A, we had a radioactive
president prematurely say,
this is absolutely magic.
A tremendous amount
of internal hostility
toward the president
inside the administration,
massive, shocking, that
was going to do anything it
could to block that.
This is my opinion.
And then, there was a
lot of premature data
that came out that was not--
that was simply like anecdotal.
And poor studies
were then done that
were looking at
it in late stage,
or later stage,
disease, where no one--
most people did not
think that's when
the drug would be effective.
And so it got-- it got sort of
a steamrolled negative thing.
If you read, there's
a couple of papers
by Joe Ladapo and others.
He's a UCLA physician who did
a compilation of the research
on hydroxychloroquine.
And it's pretty good data.
And there's a lot of studies
out that show that it seems--
I'm not an expert on
that data, by the way.
I haven't really spent a
lot of time looking at it.
It seems that it's effective
in early disease and possibly,
but we don't know, it's at least
being studied for prophylaxis.
Like you take, and I have taken
hydroxychloroquine for malaria
prophylaxis many years ago.
But it's thought,
if it's effective,
it's effective in
early stage disease.
Ivermectin I don't
know much about.
But it's sort of-- there's
pretty, very positive data
about it that again,
a lot of these studies
are criticized
because they're not
these perfect, randomized,
controlled studies.
But, as we all
know, haven't seen
a lot of randomized
controlled studies
about masks and 6-foot
social distancing.
[CHEERING]
By the way, just sort
of an interesting aside,
it has nothing to do
with their question.
But the WHO says three feet, and
many countries use three feet.
Now why is that important?
It's important to know
because, A, it shows
how arbitrary the rule is.
It's not that three feet
is the right number,
I'm not saying that.
But it also shows, if
it's three feet, that's
a game changer for a
restaurant, for instance.
You know, because
three feet away,
I mean, unless you're
with the person,
you're not sitting three
feet, you know, usually.
I mean there are
certain restaurants.
So these kinds of
things are just
pointing out how arbitrary
these rules have been.
It's clear social
distancing will eliminate
and will stop the
spread of an infection.
And my analogy is, if I'm in
Paris and you're in London,
you're breathing the
same air generally.
But you're not going to get it.
You're far enough away.
Now, I don't know
about six feet.
No one knows.
It's never been proven.
And there's a lot
of horror stories
about how the 6-foot rule came
about in that situation room.
But it happened
before I was there.
So I won't claim to know that.
But it's a joke.
The drug studies
have been perverted.
The whole climate has been
destroyed by the politics.
And it's very sad.
Because, frankly, in
my opinion, people
were killed because of the
politics of stopping the drug
data from coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Please join--
please join me in
thanking Dr. Atlas.
[APPLAUSE]